tj grooms who joins me now pastor you
say there's no incentive for leaders to
take action in chicago to combat crime
why not
because whenever you are in an area
where economically
things are disastrous
and you're in an area where there isn't
as much political engagement as it
should be
then it's going to cause people who have
power within their grasp
not to pay those areas attention and so
you would think that um people who have
the power would go to the areas where
crime and violence happens often
so that it can actually turn into a
place like highland where it doesn't
happen as often yeah well they're not
going anywhere near it i mean in your
chicago your mayor lori lightfoot is off
to london and paris to promote chicago
uh as a tourist destination while your
community continues to bleed and suffer
let's turn for a moment to philadelphia
where police are looking for seven
teenagers seen in this video beating a
73 year old man with traffic cones and
smiling as they do it james lambert died
the next day pastor why is it that we
keep seeing young kids committing these
heinous acts not only in your city in my
city of new orleans as well
because we have to recognize and
understand
that the that these kids that are
committing violent acts and even the
kids that i deal with and see on a
regular basis this is all they are
exposed to
and it and it's very difficult to expect
children and young people to overcome
what they're exposed to without giving
them something else to be exposed to and
so we have to get to a place to where we
start showing our kids and our teenagers
and people who are committing acts of
violence who has that potential to we
have to start giving them another way
and that's why i love organizations like
project hood because they do that
effectively yeah well how do we break
this and it really is a cycle of murder
of loss and you're losing a generation
particularly of young men in the inner
city how do we break that cycle pastor
well uh there's a couple of ways to
break that cycle one
we have to make sure that we have
resources for people to have employment
i the young men that i deal with on a
regular basis
that are susceptible to these type of
acts they tell me all the time pastor if
i had money if i had a job then i
wouldn't be doing some of the things
that i am doing and so
that is is a very important importance
mentorship is so important for these
young men the type of mentorship you're
providing pastor so i thank you for that
we'll keep our eye on this hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else